I know that the walking dead you were a
fan of a comic book before you were even
cast on the show yes actually my friend
Andy who's here somewhere he put me on
to it and he was like you guys check
this book out and I just read it and I
didn't really think anything of it I was
like all there's an Asian guy that's
cool and then five years later I moved
to LA and I booked it and it's crazy
because that there's asian guy in it so
you became that guy for that yes I
became that guy we have a drawing of the
character your character from the comic
book that's you why do you feel like
you're channeling him from the comic
book yeah you know I think I have better
cheekbones than him yeah and his white
eyes eyes okay well you're talking
yourself out of the role
[Applause]
that's good like three weeks now I I
have to ask you something that's three
weeks right there oh my god you're stink
you're single Stephen is this you're on
this hit show very popular with young
people is this helping you with the
ladies no why not why not IV must it
must have you your take nice dear people
say that but I don't think I mean I'm
just so crazy I I'm like not normal and
I really think like 18 20 steps ahead so
it's like oh my god that girl is so cute
I would love to date her wait a minute
what will happen when we're on her
marriage and we're on our second child
and she says hey can you cook me some
spaghetti I'm really tired I'm not sure
I've work to do some spaghetti and then
I bring this began she's like this
tastes like crap and she throws the fork
I don't want that so no thanks
[Applause]
oh I know exactly you should have got on
that show in treatment yeah you're
you're destined for a lonely life if you
keep thinking that way it's it's gonna
be good I have so many comic books